[Music]
I'm from the future I'm an actor I'm for
for I'm your friend I'm home I'm an
excellent driver I'm going to Harvard
I'm not a child I'm also just a girl hi
I'm
plenty but of course you are I am a
golden
god I am the god I am the god I'm a
goofy goo CEO I'm Spartacus I'm
Spartacus I'm
kickass I'm walking here I'm walking
here I'm a virgin I am R-rated sexy very
very dirty I'm dead I'm free I'm a
blessed man I'm home I'm hi I'm stupid
you're gay I'm not gay I'm a
heterosexual I'm gay I'm honored to be
your friend I'm a squirter J I'm a
mothering dwarf k in my ass I'm thinking
thin I'm the dude I'm not your bro and
I'm not your bra I'm the Man louder I'm
the man I'm the man up in this piece I'm
Batman I'm Batman I am Iron Man I am Gro
I'm just a cook I'm a bird I'm in love
with her I'm pregnant I'm pregnant I'm
pregnant I'm out baby I'm
M I'm so
rry I'm scared to CL close my eyes I am
so sorry now I'm not your father either
am I I'm your daddy I'm his mother I'm
your Uncle Buck I'm glad it's you I'm
building I'm in the dark I'm right here
I'm in a glass case of emotion I'm
trying to make this right I'm a future
I'm your Secret I done I'm too old for
this
I'm
finished
[Music]